[Music]
in this pandemic we are all required to
wear masks and i hope you guys are
wearing masks i hope
everyone here is wearing a mask so i do
because it feels like
the most uh responsible thing to do
isn't it
my most comfortable one is the one with
the hole in the center i always wear
that oh dude have you seen the ones
where they're making that where
it's it's still like covered but it's
like a see-through for the
for people who are hearing impaired
right so they can read this oh they can
read lips
oh that's cool legit just to me feels
like a polite thing to do more than
actually a safe thing to do i just i'm
like i'll just do this so everyone feels
comfortable around me i'm the same way
too i'm like
on one end i'm like i get it it's it's
responsible it's very considerate and
it may spread stop the spread of
diseases but at the same time i'm like
how effective is it really well it goes
against my morals
so i also want people to what moral
feels safe
about mask wearing he wants to be
himself goes against my morals but i
still want people to feel safe so what i
do when i go to supermarkets i put the
mask on backwards and i just walk in
backwards
he's still wearing him everyone feels
very safe for your sunglasses on
backwards too and your head backwards
you're just walking backwards the entire
time
anyways uh there is a content creator
by the name of alan pan he has a what
are you doing joe
i'm wearing masks you're like the mist
you're like the mr face
from the holiday you're just missing the
top part of before you're just missing
the top part for the ku klux
oh no oh there you go how about this i'm
like uh
it's like an apron but for the face okay
you look like a beekeeper with the color
that was the first month of mask wearing
when all of the masks were sold out
everywhere and everyone's just kind of
figuring it out yeah
there's people just going in yeah like
that yeah i've done that once i drove
all the way
to pick up a [ __ ] sugar fish to just
we wanted sugar fish we drove all the
way there and i forgot my mask and i had
to stand out there waiting for my order
so i was just like okay i guess i'm
doing this today they let you
yeah they're really chill about it yeah
but this is also before this is like the
early days of
like needing to do that and i don't
think people were yet like caring
about it yet so but now it seems like
everyone's tired of it people forget all
the time and i think businesses
also know that because uh we went to go
film tim's podcast
and then i got my car like valet so it's
gone already
i go to starbucks and then i'm like
they're like oh where's your mask
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my car's gone oh [ __ ]
i'm like i just do this
and they're like no and i'm like oh i
want coffee
and then they're like well we have an
extra mask and then they had a whole
stack of them
oh thank you so much yeah that's helpful
that's awesome that's really cool
starbuck's just giving you a map you
just gave me a message were you already
inside starbucks without a mask on
yeah that's why it's so dumb isn't it
i'm sorry but like
you had your birthday program you
already did all the bad things i already
smelled all the coffee beans
without a mask i'm not saying not to
wear a mask [ __ ] off or just i'm just
pointing out how
silly a lot of this i feel like if we're
in super crowded places like flying
and you're just next to people or like
yeah
wear it the whole time yeah i i do
just because yeah not because of just
for me but just for just
everything you know like there's people
um they smell
scared or whatever melon you don't want
to smell them yeah and there are times
when i just sneeze
dude i've been loving the masks because
like yeah it's like my breath is stank
or whatever
usually i'd be like oh it's popping uh a
gum or something right but now i'm just
like
[ __ ] masks saves my stink i smell it
in my own self all your own gross bread
but you're like you're immune to your
own smells though you know
not if it builds up what bro how bad is
yours then so i have my mask
and then uh that's the one that i wear
uh when i go work out
do you smell the inside of your mask
because you're breathing hard when
you're working out right so it traps
that saliva and it's your morning saliva
smell even when i
brush my teeth but then after a week for
food
yeah but after a week like on a friday
when i'm wearing the same mask i'm like
oh i really need to wash them
i'm there with you i can smell it
already oh yeah
how's your sex life geo not pregnant
we don't wear masks when we're having
sex oh i know why not
there's been some porn well because we
don't have sex
when you guys were having sex no masks
girls were wearing masks in porn now
nice really is that is that a new a new
trend joe
i don't get the point you don't get the
people yeah if it's supposed to be
fantasy
you might i mean they take it off it's
too real oh they take it oh they take it
off then why are they wearing it
i don't know it's in japanese oh okay
wait don't you understand what the [ __ ]
he couldn't understand it was in
japanese that could have been apart from
the 80s too that they've been wearing
masks
oh yeah that's true oh that's true
anyways so there's a guy named by the
name of alan pan he has a youtube
channel
uh where he has a million followers and
give us some
i know right i'm like hey let's let's
let's share a little i know we've been
stuck at like 1.9 million for like ages
i know we can't break that too i know
i want that too every time we're right
about to man
all the bots disappear
anyways um but yeah so he on his channel
this guy he
builds inventions and stuff and like
gadgets and uh
he has decided that he needs to take
matters into his own hands because he's
realizing that america
is refusing to wear masks and and like
just in
within our own la backyard like the oc
as a as a whole community you know more
or less is not
pro mask and that's a different county
yeah it is
it is but it's like our neighbors you
know and it's like funny because we're
here to drive from la to oc and then
just be in a different mindset all of a
sudden like going in a different country
yeah you go there and then they shame
you for not for
wearing them yeah yes and when you're in
l.a they shame you for not wearing a
mask
it's so opposite so weird but yeah here
is a
short video oh my god is he shooting his
face created
a machine a gun so the whole
point of this is alan was like uh well
it seems like the mat the non-mask
wearers are also the pro-gun people
second amendment he was like i will
second amendment this situation by
creating a gun that actually puts masks
on face tie by force by force
really really good really good and this
is what he came up
that with painful now
point three two one
it works this guy's [ __ ] smart he is
smart man wait how does it tie in the
back
it looked like it was like um like it's
weighted on the four ends
and then they just kind of tie each
other yeah like somehow he was able to
make it shoot out and there's like
screws uh at the ends of
the corner yeah and so it just goes out
this way but then it wraps back around
that's like what batman has exactly when
he shoots that cargo net thing
yeah they're running away and it like oh
this
that he aim properly doesn't go through
your ear i know it looks scary to do
that it looks really scary
but yeah he uh he in the video he later
on goes out to the beach
and uh instead of actually shooting
people he sets up like a dummy and then
he's inviting people to come and test
out his gun
so that is not as fun as shooting actual
people not wearing masks
but still i think that's uh fantastic
[ __ ] smart that's pretty funny
invention yeah even his shirt is
wearing a mask that's true he's on brand
that's [ __ ] tight imagine thinking of
some [ __ ] and then like some robotic
[ __ ] and then just [ __ ]
building it yeah that's pretty awesome
and then you're done i can't there's
some gun people that wear masks and some
gun people that don't wear masks too
though i'm a gun guy and i wear a mask
so we went to like a
like a the shooting competition that
happens like every month
and about half the people that are
shooting the competition with the mask
on even though we're outdoors and
there's a lot of social distancing
because there's only
like one person running the course out
of time right right and there's people
that don't wear masks because they feel
like they're playing an outdoor sport
and they don't need to wear one mask
and is there like ever a narrative or
dialogue between the people that wear
masks and don't wear masks
no it's usually hi how are you good
morning oh i see i see
that's respectful they're not putting
the guns at each other you better put it
on
it's dangerous holy [ __ ] take that mask
off this is pretty funny no i'm keeping
it on
there's like a standoff between maskers
and
non-mask sirs anti-masks
what a harder word masks are the
anti-masters
are getting more and more uh fed up
as time goes by i think the world is my
friend i think everyone's getting sick
of wearing the map
even pro masters are getting fed up to
the point where they're also anti-matter
i'm very over it
but i do it to be polite that's it i
don't think it actually does anything
about coronavirus
i don't think it does i don't give a
[ __ ] people can't get mad about that
i don't think i think even the cdc said
they don't even necessarily know
i don't think anyone knows yeah yeah and
then recently i just read an article
about
a [ __ ] the swedish version of
the foul the falsie that they have over
there right and
he's basically saying sweden we don't
need to wear masks well i think
the scandinavian countries maybe it was
sweden but they
decided to not quarantine or do anything
and they were just completely fine
throughout the whole thing
but they all they they're way less
populated than we are yeah
way less for sure they're like they're
like the size of one of our states
even the smaller ones you know not not
like california california is a
straight-up country we have like three
countries in one year i feel like
yeah norcal socal and then you got like
we're multiple countries
yeah but i don't know man it's it's
difficult to make a call because there's
so much conflicting
information yeah from different sources
you know you got
one news channel saying and one thing
another just they don't [ __ ] all
agree this even dude the testing
conflicts with itself
yeah so it's like yeah so who do we
listen to and what is the right one
because everyone claims they have the
right info
yeah so until we get the right info i
think it's best you're saying it's more
safe than sorry
do you guys when you guys see your
neighbors um
do you guys have this weird thing we're
like oh no you gotta stay six feet away
from me gotta wear a mask or like well i
see you every day anyways
yeah i even make out with my neighbors
now oh that's nice it's like oh
quarantine [ __ ] it dude let's just prove
the world that
we good and then so i knock on their
door and i just start [ __ ] making out
kissing them
our neighborhood if you walk around the
neighborhood uh like you'll
if someone's coming like you're socially
distant from them but you kind of
purposely go
opposite a little bit yeah like you
separate from them
uh yeah i walk across like they're
they're a dangerous
like homeless man because they are
actually a dangerous homeless man but i
live in a really good neighborhood
yeah and it's like it's like an old lady
walking her cute little poodle or some
[ __ ] and i'm like ugh
you disgusting homeless man that's true
yeah when i
have conversations with my neighbors we
always start off at
six feet apart maybe even more but then
like it's just so hard to hear sometimes
just like
what and then you just like kind of
naturally get closer and closer and
you're just like right here you're like
cool we're having a normal conversation
now that's the normal that's the
interaction i find myself having
yeah uh like with my neighbors like i
don't know how it is but we all kind of
generally know what six feet is
yeah so i'll see you neighbor hey how's
it going it happens in a while and then
we we walk
and then we both kind of freeze at six
feet yeah whoa whoa over there and we're
just talking
and and then i think one of us just
starts crossing over and then we get
closer yeah and by the time you're done
having a conversation you're like
shaking hands yeah your lips are
touching right
yeah before you know you're just like
here and then you just yeah they're like
this
i like what you're doing yeah did too
that's the most intimate they've gotten
in six months
well they were not trying to break the
law you know that's true
they had to maintain social distance
sensible true true
because we here follow the rules hello
guys thank you guys so
much for watching all of our videos and
i know it's been a million years in the
making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around yeah
jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you